All right. There we go. All right, guys. Welcome to the call. November 5th election day. Wow.
Here we go. Got two months left in the year. First and foremost, just to get really, we're
going to get right into it today. But one thing I wanted to say is I wanted to thank
everybody who was part of our beta test group. We appreciate you guys. I'm going to be bringing
Ryan on here in a second. We appreciate you guys putting trust in the product and knowing
we'll make sure that it's a great product. We're trying to implement. I'm giving Ryan feedback. I
hear you guys. I have my team working on it. We're trying to get as much feedback as possible.
It's not going to be perfect, but we're going to work our way towards it. We're going to allow you
guys to help us build this tool. And I'm going to be able to help take your feedback, give it to
Ryan, and create the best rank and rent tool on the internet. Okay? So anyway, I wanted to
let you guys know that we appreciate you guys being part of that beta test group.
And yeah, that's basically all I wanted to say before I bring Ryan on. I'm going to bring Ryan
Dalton, Mr. $87,000 per month. If you guys do not know Ryan Dalton, maybe you just joined the group.
Ryan joined back a little over two years ago and has scaled up to $87,000 per month. He is a master
of systems. He's a master of organization. And this was a perfect project for him to take all
of his skill sets and put it into creating the perfect tool, the only tool that you need.
And today, specifically, we're going to be talking about search volume and what the minimum search
volume needs to be for you to have confidence to go into a city, any niche. And on top of that,
we're also going to be answering questions, going into more of the tool itself for any of you guys
that had questions. I know we had the call earlier. I guess it was last night for you guys. It was
earlier today for me, and we had a bunch of really, really good questions. So any questions that you
have related to the software we want to answer, clear up, et cetera. We're going to talk about
search volume. And then if we have any time for anything else, we'll do that as well. So let me
bring Ryan on really quick and we will get going. Hold on. Three, two, one, admits.
And apparently, oh, there we go. We're working.
Yo. Can you hear me? Yeah, I got you. Beautiful. Okay. Ryan Dalton. Welcome to the call, dude.
Hey, everybody. Yeah, I know some people that they were on the call that was for me this morning.
This has been the longest day of my life. I got two hours and 11 minutes of sleep, exactly per
the watch here, per the whoop, two hours, 11 minutes. But I did get a little nappy on the couch.
Good to be back. We had Ryan on a few times and you guys should know who he is. If not, then you
guys need to be a little more active in the group. Mr. $87,000 per month joined a little over two
years ago, full-time job, family, kids, the entire thing, all the objections that people used to have
don't have time. I've got kids, blah, blah, blah. Ryan basically ruined that for all of you guys
because he's got all of those objections and he still did it. So anytime anyone tells me any of
these things, I just send them the interview with Ryan. I'm like, well, this guy did it. So it's
possible, which means it's possible for you. So what we're going to do today, guys, as I mentioned,
I want to get right into this. I want to specifically talk about search volume because
it's something that we've been talking about. We haven't been putting it off, but I've really
wanted to make sure we get it dialed in so that we don't give you guys bad advice or something
I'm not a hundred percent confident in. So over the past few weeks, since we launched this tool,
what's it been, Ryan, four and a half weeks, something like that? Yeah, about four and a half
weeks. I've been going in looking at not just one of my projects, but I've looked at like four or
five, six of my projects that are ranking very well consistently for years, looking at how many
leads they have. They're ranked really high, looking at what the tool says to them and then
saying, okay, if I was to make a guess, what's the minimum search volume that a city and niche has to
have? Okay. So anyway, Ryan, anything that you want to cover before we get started on that front
or anything that you want to chat on other than that? I just think it's a super important call.
This stuff is not static. I mean, it changes over time. So revisiting some of the fundamentals of
local lead generation is always a great way to spend some time. Search volume I've found
more and more with my agency is king, right? Where everything for me begins with search volume. So
having conversations about what people see as working and what isn't is very useful.
And search volume, guys, it's part of due diligence. And I will stand by this forever.
Due diligence is the most important step in the process, right? Because no matter how good you
are at sales, if you do a bad job on picking an area and there's no hungry business owners,
your life becomes very difficult. If you pick a really good city that's low competition,
great search volume, lots of hungry business owners, you could be a mediocre at best salesman,
not even a good salesperson, and you're going to get deals. So I truly believe that due diligence
is actually the most important step in the process. And this is part of due diligence. Now,
I did notice that there was a couple other questions like what about this, that, and the
rest. Some of those things, if we don't know the exact, we don't have a very solid answer yet per
the tool, because this is going to be our staple tool going forward, then I'm going to let you guys
know that. But specifically on search volume, we are going to address that today. Okay? So
really quick, though, just to welcome people in the call, we've got Simon, we've got Nicholas
Kudlick, we've got Beau, we've got Kevin Mijo, we've got Corey Gilbert, Mr. St. George Utah,
Ryan Martez, we've got JC Crozier, what's going on? We've got Jason Allred, Mr. Utah, Ryan,
the best example of F your excuses, a hundred percent. Corey says, Ryan Dalton, I have that
same safe. If you want to go shoot some Tannerite, let me know. Dude, let's go. Let's go, man. I put
some 556s and Tannerite with you. You guys and your Tannerite, dude. You know, it's funny. I
actually met Corey in person and we actually had the same conversation about Tannerite. So
I have a feeling he's got a few stacks of that stuff. It's good to have someone stand by. Yeah,
you have to. You have to. Okay. So guys, let's start with this. I want to start with how we
used to recommend the search volume. Okay. Now I want to go very basic. Search volume. And Ryan,
I know that for you, you do look at population a little bit. You've kind of kind of a slightly
different process. But for me, I kind of just go sheer like basically almost exclusively off of
search volume, because in my mind, it doesn't really matter. I do think population matters
to an extent because the bigger the population, typically the more competitive. Would you agree
with that? Yeah. I mean, certainly there's a correlation. I pay attention to population
insofar as I'm interested in if it's a growth area, right? Where maybe other people are not
looking because I'm able to look there and see like, all right, two years ago, this was the
population. Now it's this population. If it continues at this rate, it's this population.
And if there's people moving there, people building homes or whatever, that's going to
increase search volume over time and I can get in early. But aside from that, search volume is king
for sure. That's a good point. And when I disregard search or population, it's in the sense of like
I've been in other programs where they don't even talk about search volume. It's just like
go into a city with this kind of a population and that's it. I like what Ryan's saying and I'll give
you guys a good example. Bentonville, Arkansas, Bentonville concrete. You guys have heard me
share this example many, many times. Bentonville concrete was a very low population when I started.
The reason I was confident going into that city, guys, is because I had lived in that city for
three summers in a row and I had watched every summer that we came back. There was new
neighborhoods popping up everywhere and I had heard that Walmart had implemented this rule
that said if you want to sell to Walmart, if you are a vendor, if you are somebody that sells
jerky, for example, to Walmart, you have to have somebody from your office living in that city.
I'm like, okay, that means that if people are going to keep selling to Walmart, they have to
have somebody that lives in the city, naturally the city is going to keep growing. That was just like
an intuition gut instinct type of a decision that I made and I knew the area. I think that's really
important and we may end up adding that to the training. Real quick, how do you look at,
do you just go ahead and search population growth over the past five years for the specific city?
Yeah, so I'll use chat GPT and prompt it with a question about population growth and it'll
give me instances of cities that are growing. Then I also do what you do where I live in Tennessee
and I know which areas are growing because I know my area and then I know areas where friends live
and I just listen. I'm always thinking about local lead generation. They're talking about their new
you know move to some area in Tennessee and they're talking about how everyone's moving
there and how it's the new like little darling hotspot. I think probably a good spot for a site
and so I'll go look at that and see like, okay, the numbers are not quite what I want them to be
just on its face but I know this area is growing so I'm going to see what happens and usually turns
out pretty good. I like that. Give us an example. You don't have to give us too much your secret
sauce but when you say a prompt with chat GPT, what do you mean? Do you say, hey, what are some
of the areas, what cities in the US, what cities in the Midwest have a 200% increase in population
over the past five years like something like that? Yeah, you can't really go wrong with your prompt
if you're trying to get it population growth. I start pretty wide. I start just in the United
States and I say give me the suburbs in the United States that have the greatest population
growth over the last, over the previous two years and it'll think for a second and then it'll spit
out you know however many, right? I can tap it and say give me the most recent 20 and that's where
I'll start my due diligence, right? Where I'll look at, okay, these are growing and maybe these
are off the radar of other lean generators. They're not looking at these yet and that can
also filter by population size. So if I think that you know the population is too big and it's growing,
I could say give me populations under you know 100,000 and then I'll take that and plug it into
search volume tools and look at, okay, what is the actual search volume? Because I don't really care
like you said about population being like the metric. I want it to be what is the actual search
volume but I will start with is this an area that is trending because trending growth means
that there's people that are buying things. They have to build. They have to you know refurbish
homes. There's people that are probably going to invest in those markets that are looking to
replace their driveways and their brick and those kinds of things. So genius. I think that's really,
really smart. So anyway that's just something to think about guys. One other little wrinkle
and guys, the answer that we're going to come give you here in just a moment on the search volume
side per what RankinRent Engine says, there are going to be some caveats to it, okay?
So let's, I'm trying to think. I don't think we necessarily need to show this on the RankinRent.
So what I'll do, maybe I'll just discuss what I think is going to be the, I'm trying to think
what would be the best way if I could, do we think we need to show this or we could just kind of
discuss it and then we can get into the tool after? Yeah, let's talk through it and then we
can show it. Okay. So I'm going to pull up some of the metrics that I found. Let's see. Let me go to,
so here's what I did guys. All right there. So as I told you was I was coming up with this
and again, the thing that we're addressing is what, when you're doing your due diligence,
what is the minimum search volume that can give you the, at least in that area that says, hey,
I know at the very least there's going to be enough volume because some of the issues that
people run into is they go into a city, it looks good, it's low competition, it's the right niche,
you know, whatever, and they start running ads and they get a couple leads and then it's like,
it just dies, right? Or I don't know, have you ever had this happen, Ryan? You build a website,
you rank it and you're still only getting like 10 leads and you're like the number one person.
Have you ever had that happen or have you never gone to a city that has that low search? Many
times, many times. And the mistake, the number one mistake that I made when that's happened
is I get impatient and I need it. I did that in, I'll just say, I did that in Selena, Texas,
the suburb of, I think it's the Dallas, Fort Worth area. And it was not getting what I wanted. I
thought it's going to go great. And I just got impatient and I was like, I'm not renewing this
domain. I'm getting rid of this domain. I don't just nuke the site, just get rid of it, right?
I don't want a bunch of riffraff in my site portfolio. The mistake I made is that that city
is still growing, right? It's still like, there's only so much space in the Dallas, Fort Worth area.
And so it's going to eventually be within my parameters, right? And it might go from,
10 leads to 20 leads over the course of the next couple of years per month. And I should have kept
it, right? So I just let those sit because all that's going to happen is that domain is going to
age. It's going to get hit with some more backlinks. It's going to, and it'll be number one forever.
You can't beat that very easily. That's so hyper local that you're glued to the top at that point.
Glued, glued. So that's a good point. And I actually have a situation like that as well.
And just because I don't check it long enough, it was kind of pissing me off. It wasn't getting
enough leads. We got a deal, but it was very low. And then the city just started growing. It's a
city in Utah. And it's kind of like, over the past, this year, I'll give you an example,
looking at the data right now, this is a city of the population of 35,000. And it's averaged,
there isn't concrete. It's averaged 13.1 calls per month. This is through October 30th. And it's
averaged another 3.7 per month with the quote form. So I'm averaging close to 18 leads per month.
And I almost ripped the city. It's not making me a ton of money. It's making me like 600 bucks
a month. But dude, 500, 600 bucks a month, go find that on a real estate deal right now.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. And where else is that business owner going to get leads?
Exactly. What other option do they have? If you're getting 18 leads a month in that area,
and you're number one, and you're running ads, and you're doing everything right,
what other options do they have at that point? You're locked in with that business owner.
100%. 100%. So here's the projects I looked at. I want to give you guys kind of a range.
I looked at, let me see. We got one, two, three, four. I looked at five different projects.
And when I did the training before version one and version two, I basically just took one project
because it was ranking really well. That was Bentonville Concrete. And I said, okay,
I know how many leads this is getting. It's ranking in the GMB. It's ranking in the maps.
And I want to compare that with what the tool says. Well, one thing that happened that I didn't
even think about is as we start to talk about Bentonville Concrete, the people in the group,
and maybe even in the free group, are searching Bentonville Concrete. So I think, I personally
think it had an effect and kind of skewed the numbers a little bit on that city. It drove the
cost up significantly on the cost per click and everything else. So I ended up looking at five
different projects. Of those, one, two, three of those are in concrete. One of them is in towing
and one of them is in duct cleaning. I kind of wanted to get a little bit of a mix.
We had a ranging population. One of them was a 35,000 population. All the way up to the highest
was a 95,000 population. So nothing that's too big, okay? But here's what I came up with. And
this is what Ryan and I, after discussing with his research, my research, is that we don't have
an exact, exact, exact, but we have a range. And what we mean by that is if you go into a city
that is very low-hanging fruit, very non-competitive, low CPC, not much competition,
that you can just tell the people that are in the, that are ranking for those keywords,
brand new websites, or they're not very old, they don't have much content, they don't have
much backlinks. It looks like just a bunch of hillbilly freaking people ranking against you.
In those situations, we can safely say 50 on it, again, using the rank and rent engine search tool,
due diligence tool. If it says 50, you're in good hands. That's on a low competition
area. If it's on a medium competition area where, okay, a couple of your competitors on,
you know, for your main keywords, they have a pretty good website. Maybe you're going up
against a rank and rent person that's a medium competition. You could still rank,
but it's going to be a bit more difficult. Maybe the CPC is tipping closer to five,
maybe even slightly over. You want to make sure you're at least 70, okay? And again,
this is on your main keyword, your main keyword. What was the other thing? Oh,
then the last thing I was going to say, and on those cities that are high competition,
you shouldn't be going into anyway, you freaking dummies. No, I'm just kidding.
But if it's high competition, you shouldn't be going into it. So if it's medium competition,
make sure it's 70. If it's low competition, 50 you can get away with. And that's good. I
feel pretty dang confident about saying that. Now, keep in mind, if you're running ads,
the ads during the winter, during certain times of the year, it's going to be up and down a bit.
But we know that if we can get the ads going, if we can get ranked organically,
and you know, in some cases, maybe grab a GMB if you get lucky, then you're going to be in
great shape. So anything you want to add to that, Ryan, I know that's like a bit anticlimactic. Maybe
you guys expect it to be something different, but again, this is not with any tool because we're not
before it was use any tool. We're specifically talking about rank and rent engine with this.
And that's why we wanted to wait to come out with this. So go ahead, Ryan.
Totally. I think Nick nailed it. I agree with this. This is my assessment as well.
These things change over time. This is why Nick's group, Digital Landlords, you know, why you're
staying on the cutting edge of the trade craft of this industry is really important because these
are not, it's not static. These are things to revisit and these things to look at. But there
are some things that are like timeless principles. One of them being that search volume is going to be
the largest like driver for success for what a market looks like. And so really paying attention
to what's succeeding and what isn't matters a lot. Those numbers are, I totally agree with those
numbers. The only little thing that I would add to that is that, and I think I saw a question kind
of getting to this in the chat, that the search volume for the primary keyword should include
variants of that keyword. So for example, concrete contractor, contractor near me, right? Those are
going to, if you have like 40 for one and 20 for the other, that's showing 60 between the two of
those. That's like, that's your primary keyword and a variant of it. That's going to get you the
results that you're looking for. Okay. I have a question for you. I'm curious your thoughts.
Let's say I go into rank and run engine. I'm doing concrete. I have concrete contractor,
concrete, concrete sidewalk, concrete driveway, concrete company, all the main keywords of our
keyword list. My main keyword has 50 and all my other keywords show zero. What are you going into
this? Low competition. If it's low competition, I'd try it and see what happens. It's generally
not a good sign if the core keyword list has zero as search volume, because I found that those are
likely often true. However, the caveat that I give on this is that if it shows zero for those and you
go into it and try it, there are examples I found where it has turned out awesome. So it's worth
trying is what I would say, especially with you guys that do the pre-selling method. It's worth
trying because what do you have to lose, right? A little bit of ad spend to know if it works or
it doesn't, and it's a place that others will overlook, right? Because they're saying like,
oh, this is too low, whatever. But these tools, even the very best like rank and run engine pulls
directly in from Google. Google Keyword Planner is the best, right? That is Google saying, here's what
we're seeing in our search ecosystem. And that is the standard, right? And so we're pulling in API
data from them. And so if Google is saying that, sometimes they don't always know perfectly. And
if Google doesn't know, these other tools sure don't know. So you might be able to find one where
you're going to be able to win and you're not going to have anyone that's going to come in and try to
catch you before you can close the business owner. So I've had that happen before as well. So it
doesn't deter me. That's another thing that I like. When I was using SEMrush before, it seemed
for whatever reason I would type in, let's say Bentonville concrete, it would show nothing. And
then I type in concrete Bentonville AR, and it would show 50. And it was so confusing. But the
way that I kind of went after it, I was always like, I was guessing a bit, but I was like, well,
if I see at least two keywords, two variations, and I have all these different variations I would
try, okay, then I'm good. Like with St. George, for example, St. George, people spell it S-T
George. Some people spell it S-A-I-N-T George. So I'd have to try all these variations. So anyway,
it's just nice because I'm able to just go and look at all the keywords at once if I'm like,
okay, I want to try just a slight difference. Yeah, I can go change it all at once and run them
instantly. But I definitely agree, guys. That's the beautiful thing about doing the pre-song.
I was just going to say, Ryan, if I were to ask you, hey, with that same scenario, 50 search volume,
zero on the other keywords, would you go and build a website there by the domain, do the whole thing?
I bet you your answer would be no, because you're not 100% confident. But I'd be willing to try it
for 100 bucks, right? Throw 100 bucks ads out. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I don't think there's a wrong
answer there. Some people will put up sites just to put up a site and see what happens and then
let it sit. And then the worst case scenario is, is two years later, you've got a domain age
of two years that no one can touch you on if they try to come in there, at least on that,
on your domain age. But it makes way more sense if you're optimizing for speed and just trying
to see which one is going to land to, hey, throw something up there, run some ads to it. If it
doesn't work, move on. 100%. And I would argue, guys, if you are going into a niche like a concrete
and you find a city that's really low-hanging fruit and it's questionable, you know that this
example I'm giving you guys with the 35,000 population, it's slowly started to grow.
You know people need concrete. So even if you build it and there's not a ton of leads,
there's always a deal to be had. But because I believe in pre-selling, because I only sell
using the pre-selling method, I know that some of you guys have been frustrated in the past
because you go in, it looks good. It's low-hanging fruit. It's kind of on that teetering edge
of volume. You do the ads and then all of a sudden you start like, it goes like a week and
you don't see anything. So if you want to be very, very, very, very conservative,
I would say 70 and above, as long as it's medium competition or less, you're good to go. But again,
if it's low competition, I think you could go as low as 50 and be pretty safe. But again,
there's variables. It's hard to just give a black and white. If there's no volume for the
ancillary keywords, that could be a red flag. If there's just all kinds of different little
tiny factors that you need to consider. So a couple of questions I want to address really quick.
Gina says, I know a city near us in Georgia, but there is not a great search volume.
Do you still go into it? I think she's referring to probably a city that's growing.
She said there's not great search volume. I think in that case, just like what you just said,
you can kind of get an age domain going, kind of make a long-term play, but you're probably not
going to see a lot right out the gates, even if you run ads, if there's not much search volume.
What are your thoughts? Yeah. It depends on your perception of that city, I think. So I've got a
city in Tennessee that is really small on the search volume numbers, do not look good. But I
know that that city is growing. I know that there are people moving there, that people want to live
there, that it's got a upward trajectory that is unmatched by any other city really in Tennessee
right now. So I put one there and that site kills it. It's doing great. So Gina, I'd say like, look,
it depends on the way that you build your agency and your own personal approach to
your risk assessment, right? Are you willing to see what happens if you put a hundred bucks
of ads into it? Because it could mean that you find something that no one else is looking at
and no one else is going to find. And if you do, that's a win, right? In my agency, I tend to go
for those things. I tend to just say, hey, let's try it out. Let's see what happens and experiment.
A lot of this business model I've found is try it, right? Just see what happens. And if it works,
you've got a winner. And if it doesn't work, at least now you know, and you're not going to
just always be wondering about it. Right. I think that's solid advice. Richard says,
for the main keyword question mark, what about the long tail keyword? I think we addressed that,
right? Maybe he said that before we got into it, but we kind of addressed that, correct?
Yeah. Yeah. I think it's helpful to understand why would someone search for a long tail keyword?
In your own search habits, why would a person search habits? Why would they search for a
long tail keyword? And think about if I'm living in Memphis and I want a concrete contractor,
I'm just going to search concrete contractor, right? Because I don't need to search. Google
knows where I live. It's going to pull up local search. If someone searches the long tail keyword,
concrete contractor in Memphis, Tennessee, they probably do not live in the Memphis area. So
they're looking from outside. Who looks from outside of a city? General contractors, builders,
investors, people that are looking to do projects in the city, commercial, people looking for
commercial work that manage a commercial facility in the city. So I found that if the
long tail keyword has search volume, it probably is a high growth area because it means that people
from outside the city who have money, who want to invest in properties in that city by doing some
kind of project related to that keyword are searching for it, right? That's kind of the
psychology behind long tail keywords that I found has been indicative of a growth area.
Okay, let's keep moving along. And guys, if you have any questions related to the search volume
topic before we get into more of the software side. By the way, I didn't even mention this
at the beginning, which is bad, but we're going to be, again, I said this at the beginning,
we appreciate everyone that did the beta stuff. We're like one month, our original deal, we gave
everybody two months of free beta, right? Was that what it was? Or two months of 20% off.
And anyway, we just appreciate that feedback. And I know we've implemented, you've implemented
quite a few of the changes already, haven't you, Ryan? Yeah. Yeah. So thanks to everyone that did
beta. Some of these are here. So Richard particularly has been super helpful. He submitted
a bunch of tickets. You guys, this is made by the people that do this business model. This isn't
made by some corporation that's sitting in Silicon Valley. This is made by people that are doing
rank and rent, people that are industry leaders in this area that have built agencies that are
successful, what works, what doesn't. That's how this tool was created. So we're continuing that
approach in the way that we build rank and rent engine, right? If you're a user and you're like,
hey, be cool if it did this, be cool if it did this. We have a feature request that you could
put in and that goes straight to my inbox. And I look at those and I'm like, you know what?
That'd be great. Let's do that. And then I just task out the developers and they go and they create
it, right? We add it to the product roadmap. So over the course of beta, we found edge cases
and things like that that were important for you guys to have it in the platform.
And we made those updates. And so it's been really, really useful. And part of the,
there was a discount for the first two months for people that were the early signups for beta.
And we really appreciate you guys. Yeah. Quick question, just a clarification, Ryan.
The people that did do beta, if they want to, are they able to tap into an extended
discount based on what we set up or do we have to, or is it just, is it done?
Yeah. If they've already made an account and they took advantage of the beta pricing,
that was for early access for the folks in the beta. And so they've got that.
We'll have deals and things like that in the future. They'll get access to things that come
out later on just as a gesture of saying, thank you. But they got locked into that early pricing
from the job. Also for you guys that are in this, we're going to make sure that we take care of you
guys above everybody. So just keep that in mind. And again, we just want to say we appreciate the
feedback. Okay. Bo says, okay, this one I'm going to read the question. You can give your feedback.
I'm going to give my feedback and I'm going to tell you what my answer is. But he says,
can you touch on CPC on Rare? Before I read the whole question, I'm going to let you know this,
Bo, is that I have a pretty solid answer because of course we're looking at this. There's another
question that's related to the backlinks. There's a couple different components of due diligence.
We're just making sure that we're dialed in. On the CPC, I'm at the same place I was a few weeks
ago with the search volume, which is I'm in, this campaign's performing well. How does it look
inside of RankinRen Engine? Okay. Now I can confidently say this is what it should be. So
I don't have a solid answer. Do this every time. Is it the average of this for you just yet? But I
just will answer by saying that's what I'm working on now. Now that we have the search volume piece,
now we're working on what the CPC should be according to Rare, as well as the backlinks
as well. So I don't know, Ryan, do you have anything else you want to add on that?
Yeah. I'd say that you're trying to get on the high top of page to get the most leads,
but it's not the end of the world if you don't. This goes back into like, this is a little bit
squishy, right? You're going to have to try it out. You're going to have to see what works for you.
And then see what kind of results that you're actually getting. So if I see a high top of page
bid that is like 20 bucks, I'm not going to even fool with it, right? But if I see one that's $10
and then the low top of page bid is $1 and it's averaging at five, I'm totally comfortable with
that, right? Because what I'll do is also run ads that are a little bit off hours as well. So starting
at 7.30 in the morning through, I don't know, 7 p.m. at night where others are not running ads,
I'm going to take advantage of that high top of page bid when others are not running ads. Maybe
there's end at 5 p.m. and mine runs until 7 p.m. I'm going to get cheaper ad clicks in that two
hour delta between those times. So there's strategies and tactics that you can deploy to
take advantage of the less expensive clicks. But I don't worry about the high top of page bid if I
think that on an average across my keywords that I'm going to do okay for my campaign forecasting.
Beautiful. So yeah, Bo, stay tuned. We'll have more details on that. I would rather let you know,
say that to you than give you some random answer. I have to come back and correct. So anyway,
so guys, that's search volume, okay? 50 on the low end, low competition, 50, medium competition,
70. If you want to be extra safe, do 70 and above. To be honest, if it's your first project,
maybe make sure it's 70 and above. But at the end of the day, guys, make sure that we're following
the exact recipe, right? I've given you the recipe of how to bake the perfect cake.
Can you deviate from it and still have success? Yeah, some of you guys have probably done that on
accident and still have success. And then you get in your head, oh my gosh, this is untrue, but
that's an anomaly. And we've done this a lot of times. I've lost a lot of money. I've made the
mistakes. So the closer you can get to the advice that we're giving you, it's because we've tried
it, we've tested it, and that is what we've seen to work. Can it still work if you deviate slightly?
Yes. But every time you deviate, you're running the risk of messing up that recipe that actually
works. All right. That is, I think, all the questions that we had so far on search volume.
We've nailed that. I know you guys have been waiting on that. If anyone has any clarifications,
keep going. Other than that, Ryan, why don't we open back the tool? I know last time,
I'm going to give you co-host, I know last time we literally only got to talk about
due diligence. We got to talk about the Explorer website, kind of do the metrics on that.
We didn't get a ton into the project stuff, the list of projects, the CRM, that kind of stuff. So
let me give you co-host real quick, sir. Let me see why this doesn't work. Hold on.
All right. Beautiful. Okay, done.
Cool. Fire it up. Where do you want to go with it? Where do you want to take this train today?
I just want you to give them a bit more. Last time when we talked, I always get hung up talking
and talking and talking about the due diligence, because to me, that's the easiest way that I could
just see how valuable this is, because that's how much time it took me to do due diligence
when I was coming up and doing them literally on sheets of paper. But there's so much more
that this does. I think more of the project management, show them more on what they can
do with the CRM, just some of that stuff, especially for the people that maybe weren't
on the call last time. I don't think we had a ton of people on the last time we did it. We
didn't promote it super hard because we were just doing a beta anyway. I think we could also talk
about the Keyword Planner, but let's just get into this. Guys, for those that have no idea what
that we're talking about, this is Rank and Run Engine. This is something that Ryan's been working
on for 15 months. It's the version 2.0 of what he's used to scale his agency. It's our go-to
standard tool that we are going to be using exclusively because it's getting data directly
from Google and because we can control it and we can give Ryan feedback and a host of different
reasons. It's super affordable. It's less than the price of a tool of it, like SEMrush, et cetera.
But that is what this is, and we're just going to be talking about that a bit today. For those of
you that did not get the beta code, you can message me and I have a code that you guys can use as a
launch code that you guys can access as well. If you were not part of the beta and you're
interested, message me. I'll send you a code. We can go from there. Ryan, let's go into some
of these different features, some of these different benefits that this tool has.
For sure. Let's talk about Bo's question. Bo asked about the difference between the low
top of page bid and the high top of page bid. This is Keyword Planner. We're going to do the
keyword masonry and we're doing it in Knoxville. You guys that are building your agencies need to,
one of the most important things you can understand about this keyword tool is some of them are going
to have local cities that are smaller. Some of them have DMA regions, which are much larger.
You can go into bigger markets sometimes if you know that your search volume is good and your cost
per click is really low. This is an example. Brick related things in the Knoxville area.
I'm not saying that this meets the population requirements. I'm not saying that it's low
hanging fruit. I'm just using this as an example to answer Bo's question. I had this pulled up.
He was asking about the difference with low top of page bid and high top of page bid.
Google's saying, hey, it's $1.43 per click for the low and $3.92 for the high. That's awesome.
That's a great keyword. Some of these, though, guys are more expensive. I'm going to do masonry
and masonry contractor near me. You can see that the difference between four bucks and $33 almost
is pretty significant. There's other keywords in here that are going to be gold mines. Let me just
do bricks, veneers. This goes to Gene's question a little bit about building a good keyword list.
Look at this. 140 search volume and less than $2. Just because an industry has those really,
really high dollar amounts doesn't mean that it's not viable. You can find these keywords
that people look for brick veneers. That's a really high ticket service. You get to re-brick
a whole house with brick veneers and it's going to be really expensive. You can get that click
for less than two bucks. Until you and I talk, I didn't even know what that was.
If somebody's searching brick veneers, they are buying the service. They are in buy mode. That
means you've gone down the rabbit hole a little bit in your research. Am I correct in that?
Yeah, man. Yeah. They're looking for ... Brick veneers is a specialty brick service that
it's not a DIY thing, man. You're not doing DIY brick veneers usually unless you're
Bob Villa, right? It's just not happening. Another is tuck pointing.
Hold on. Is brick veneering just like doing veneers on your teeth? Do they whittle your
teeth down so you look like a gremlin and then they put the caps on?
Yeah. Yeah. They do that to your house. That's crazy, dude.
They put brick veneers on the outside of the house to give that timeless brick look. It's
really popular. You can see just on the search volume here how popular this is.
That's another money keyword that ... There's these variations here, right? Brick paneling.
People that search this don't know to call it brick veneers, but they know what it is.
Thin brick, brick veneers. You can see that even though if you do masonry contractor and you're
mean, it's 30 bucks a click. The people that are looking for brick veneers are looking brick
paneling and these other brick-related overlay type keywords. They're looking for a masonry
contractor. You don't have to get totally hung up on, oh, it's $30. This isn't going to work.
This is just another way to search for that primary keyword.
I have a question, Ryan. Let's say that we were looking that up. Let's say we're in masonry.
We find out masonry is 30 bucks a click top, the high end. You're like, okay, I could go and target
terms like this on my ads. On your SEO side, would you still be targeting the term masonry
as your H1 on your page title, that kind of thing, or would you change that strategy at all?
100%. This is still going to be masonry near me. They're looking for a brick masonry contractor.
That's the expensive one. It's $18. It's a cost per click average. This is still what I'm targeting.
This is still my primary keyword. It's still going to my H1. It's still going to my landing page,
but if I run ads to it, it is probably not going to make the mix.
The reason I wanted to bring that up, guys, is that the thing that's interesting is when you see
high CPC, it's terrible for ads, but nothing's better than when you have organic
leads coming in for those high CPC terms. That usually means that they're very highly sought
after. The good strategy is get your clicks for the low cost terms, start ranking for the high
cost terms, and between the two, you have a freaking smasher of a website. It also looks
like the freaking hooptie of websites, the Geo Metro of websites while you're at it.
Yeah, absolutely. That's a great strategy. You're able to take advantage of these other
keywords that are overlooked. Let's see. Did I misspell that? Tuck, oink, ding.
Okay. Spelling is hard when I'm doing it live. All right. This one is another good example of
a keyword that between tuck pointing and tuck pointing near me and some of these others,
there might be 40 or 50 searches a month, but it's going to be super cheap clicks.
That's not a DIY thing. Someone's paying a mason to come out and do that. Be mindful of,
just because you see that high top of page bid doesn't mean that it's not a viable market.
Look for some of these keywords that they're looking for a specialist to do. They're just
not using the specialist primary keyword that has that high cost per click.
Gina had a really interesting suggestion. I don't know if you want to wrap up this thought,
or if you're done, but maybe you could show ... You don't have to show a full,
but maybe we could pick a niche and you could show us how you go about building a keyword list
using rank and run engine, coming up with ideas, seeing what's highly searched,
that kind of thing. I don't know if that's something you could show us.
Yeah, dude. Let's do it live. What do you got? Give me a niche. What do you want to do?
Let's stay away from the regulars, but let's keep it still. Let's ask Gina. Gina, what do you got?
Give us something that's not concrete, tree service, spray foam insulation, and we'll do it.
If it is one of those, then let's keep going. I love those niches. I still make money in those
niches. We're still closing deals in those niches, but I guess I'm just a little tired of talking
about concrete, personally. It's only because I've been doing it for three years. I'm still
going to do it. I just am tired of talking about it. I love some demo.
Yeah, exactly. If you're watching this car right now, demo, I've got some demo clients and they do
not bat an eye at $1,500 a month. They don't think twice about it because the demo jobs,
entry-level demo jobs are high ticket, but they'll get jobs that are like,
I had a demo job come in for one of my clients that was a quarter million dollars.
Crazy. Yeah. Let's do some demo. Let's do demo.
Just to answer Gina's question really quick, she says, are we not using the Google Trends?
No, guys. We want to see how Ryan's using this to build his keyword list. Remember, we're redoing
the training 3.0. In the meantime, you can still follow everything the exact same. The training is
still how I build my keyword list. You got to remember, this tool just came out three,
four weeks ago. I'm still taking my strategy using how I used to and then how am I going to
use it here, looking at what Ryan's doing. But no, for anybody that's confused, just keep following
the training. It still works as how I've continually made thousands and thousands of dollars, but we
want to see how Ryan's using Rare because we want to utilize and just beat the heck out of this tool
as much as possible if we're going to have it. Let's do demolition and let's build a keyword
list. But anyone else that's confused, keep doing what you're doing. This is just to see how Ryan's
doing. This could also be a good way to generate additional ideas if you're hung up trying to find
and build that keyword list. Let's see how you do it, man. Yeah, 100%. Guys, we're showing you a
part of the keyword analysis process, Nick, and the training starts with Google Trends.
You can look at the national, are we in the right ballpark for the cities we're looking at?
That's very similar to talking about the chat GPT approach, looking nationally at what our
search volume is. We're a little bit further along in that part, and we've got some areas
that we're looking at now. This is not removing that part of the training. That's still essential,
but we're just zoomed in a little bit here. Let's say that we see demolition is trending
in Tennessee, and demolition is interesting, guys, because there's only so much real estate
in a city, and there's only so much good real estate in a city. If there's old properties that
are in a blight district or there's an area that is growing, but there's old properties there that
people are buying up, they have to demolish those old properties to build new ones. It's required.
There's only got so much space. Demolition is a really, really good one to go into. I'm a big fan
of demolition. Demolition, let's do Tennessee. Let's just see what happens with some Knoxville.
Just already in here, so let's just search it and see what happens.
You guys can see 260 searches, probably three bucks a click.
3F357 for demolition. Let's see what happens. That's more expensive. Demolition companies near me,
though, is a good one. That's six bucks. What I'll do is I'll go through demolition-related
keywords, demolition, demolition contractor, demolition company, demolition services,
and I'll start looking at what these look like. As I build up my keyword list, I'm going to have
my core, my primary keyword is going to be demolition or demolition contractor,
and then I'm going to start adding these in as part of my core keyword list. It's also going
to depend on what my vision is for this actual site. Do I want other services related demolition,
because demolition guys will often also do excavation and trenching. It just depends on
how you want to eventually build out the site. If you're wanting to just specialize in just straight
up demolition, there's a lot of good keywords here that when you add all these up, there's
probably another 100 or plus or more searches per month in this market just for demolition.
Let's do another city. Let's do some nationals growing. These are bigger areas, but you can see
that there's a lot of opportunity in these areas. Six bucks a click, six bucks a click,
demolition companies near me. I will go and I'll build up my keyword list by looking at the primary
keyword, making sure that it's got solid search volume standards that Nick and I talked about a
second ago. Then I'll add in all these additional ones as part of my secondary keyword list where
these are not primary, but they're variants of the primary. When you add all these up,
you're going to get calls where other people are not optimizing for these keywords, and you're
going to get the call for house demolition companies near me or pool removal contractors,
because the guys that do demolition will also do some of these specialty services
related to demolition. You can add these in commercial demolition contractors. That is a
great keyword, and people are probably not looking for it. Build these out right into a sheet,
and just add these in, or I'll go straight to my due diligence tab and I'll make a due diligence
record where I'll add in these keywords that I see coming up over and over with good search volume.
Yeah, what's up, Nick? I know a couple of different ideas that I would find this,
but for somebody that may be asking, let's say that Gina thinks of a brand new service. She's
like, I'm going to go into excavation or demolition. How do you go about finding out what's the main
keyword? Do you just go off of what it's called and use your intuition and say, well, if it's
excavation, it's probably excavation. Let me look at the difference between excavation and
excavation contractor, excavation company. How do you determine that main keyword? I'm curious
how you do it. I'll let you guys know how I would do it and how I would find it really quickly.
Yeah, I would love to hear Nick's answer to this. I think this requires just a little bit of
speculation, but making just sort of informed guesses. For example, there's a difference
as in industries. If I just type in concrete, that is not going to give me the results that I want.
If I just do straight up concrete, if we just use a tried and true example, there's 1900 searches,
but that's not what I want because people are going to use that to find ready mix and delivery
by the yard or whatever. But if I do demolition, and I know this because I've had campaigns that
run ads and I've seen my organic clicks, demolition is likely going to, you can't buy just a demolition
product. You know what I'm saying? It's not a product and a service. It's an action. It's a
service. You're doing demolition. Now, what do they mean by that? Do they mean interior
remodeling demo? That's very different than destroying a structure, removing it away,
and then clearing the land. That's going to be more likely to be a demolition contractor.
But in this case, that keyword or demolition company is a good one. In that case, I will look
at the keyword and I will make a judgment about, okay, this is not a product. Concrete is the
product, but it's also a keyword that is going to be used in concrete contractor. I want to make
an assessment about whether this is going to be likely someone calling for someone to do this
specialty service. In this case, demolition would be one that I would add. A demolition contractor
very often would add that to. Concrete would not add that. Concrete contractor would be a great
one. It varies by industry. I just really make a judgment call about really what the search volume
looks like and how I would search for it, frankly. What would you do, Nick?
I would be lazy and just tick-tapping other people's work. I'd go to some major cities,
type in what I think it is, type in demolition. I'd look at the top three results in the organic,
and I would look at the page title because those guys most likely are paying SEO companies. Make
sure it's big cities, competitive cities, Atlanta, L.A., whatever. I guarantee the page title, the
thing that shows up in the SERPs, the first word or the first two words is going to be demolition
service, demolition service. That would be an interesting one to look at right there, demolition
contractor. I would look at three, four cities and then I would come up with two, three ideas.
Then I would go pump it into RankinRent engine and I would see which one. Again, this is just when
you go into a new niche. This is why it's so important to stay in the same niche because
concrete, me and you, we can just go off the top of our head and know our keyword list.
I'm curious to see what demolition service is.
It's going to pull up 10, but let's do a bigger...
So it's going to pull up these related keywords and there's...
And that's just to generate ideas. I would go in and do that in like three, four cities and I'd
look, okay, I keep seeing demolition service, I keep seeing demolition contractor and then I would
just look at that inside of this tool and go, all right, this is probably my target keyword.
You could also go to the website, look at the H1, look at the page title, that kind of stuff
right there. Full service demolition. Is that a Legion?
I don't know, man.
It almost looks like it, but then it's, I mean, it's kind of got a brand. They did a good job
with it is. So again, these are just some ideas, but once again, this is the reason why you guys,
if you go and you take the time to learn a niche, you don't have to keep... There you go.
That's a Legion site.
Yeah, we've built that for one of my students.
Oh, there you go.
This is a lead generator in Atlanta and you can see that he's made it in, right? So look how...
Then that's a good looking site. Go up again, it's best demolition service.
Oh, you're looking at the...
The headline, yeah, right there. Demolition contractor, sorry. Yeah, that's another good
thing. If you could find a lead generator, it doesn't necessarily mean they know what
they're doing, but usually they know what they're doing more than everybody else. And if they're
ranking, they probably know what they're doing. So these are just ideas. You could also ask in
the group if you want. That's another idea, you know? But these are just when you're going
into a new niche. And I just wanted to bring that up because she asked to build a keyword
list from scratch. So again, guys, you could stick with how we do it until I'm continuing
to do it, but I might, based on this, now that we're using rank and run engine, the version 3.0
might have a slightly different way that we do it if it's faster, if it's more accurate, et cetera.
So that's why I was curious to see your process.
Totally, man. Yeah, it's great being on this call with you guys. Looking at the
the fundamentals and constantly revisiting the fundamentals. I think that there's a lot
of entrepreneurs that are very, very successful that I listen to that talk about, you know,
revisiting your business model from first principles over and over and over and over again,
right? Because there's people that are not doing that. They're getting left in the dust because
the world changes, search changes, search volume changes. And I love that Digital Landlords is
always thinking about like, how do we make sure that we're going to consistently get results for
students? It's cool talking about this with you guys today.
Gina, just to clarify Gina's question before we end this, she said, I'm just a little thrown off
by her searching for it, I guess. Do you always search for Tennessee or do you choose a large
city? I think it kind of goes back to the whole concept of like, people are people are people.
The thinking with the Google Trends is that you can kind of cast a wider net.
And so I think for now, I still like the, let me ask this, can you search on rank and
rent without putting in a city and just go globally or nationwide? Or do you have to put
in a city? It's made for local search. Okay. So maybe what you could do, Gina,
to start to start to get ideas is just use trends to find those main terms and then come
into rank and rent in the city you're looking at and then start going from there.
Yeah. Yeah. I think, again, let's talk about earlier, like we were zoomed out
and we were looking at trends, we were talking about JetCheap ET and prompting it for search.
And then we zoom in the next part and we look at, you know, at the city level, right? The state
city level and see like, okay, what is it actually? We know what the trend is and saying, hey, here's
the trend, but what is in reality, right? Because we got to make a decision about whether it's a
Bible market based on the very specific data as we have it for that area. Yeah.
Yeah. Anyway, beautiful. Well, Jahil just joined and then Corey helped him out. He said 50th low
competition. If you want to be very conservative, Jahil 70 is the very bottom of the list if you
want to be very conservative. But, you know, this is what we found right now. As we roll out version
3.0, I'm going to keep testing. I'm going to keep looking at this. Now I can go into rank and rent
engine, refresh it and see if anything changed right before I release it and see if those numbers
are any different. But as of right now, standing November 5th, 2024, 50 with a low competition
and 70 with a medium competition. And that is that. So I also want to just mention one more thing.
I do appreciate, I see those of you that post your wins and share your success and everything,
I know it takes time. But I know, I don't know about you, Ryan, but when I was in these groups,
like just learning the ropes, dude, I would feed off of these posts. When I saw people, even if
they just got their first lead in, they just got their first website up, they just, you know,
sometimes hearing about somebody's like failure even gave me encouragement. Like, hey, I just
cold called this business owner. I got kicked in the teeth and whatever. So anyway, I just want
to let you guys know, I really appreciate you guys sharing those wins in this group and the free group
and that it's complete social proof. It helps us a ton. And just to want you guys know that I
noticed that. So anything else you want to add, Ryan? Thanks for having me on, man. I am always
happy to be with you guys and Digital Landlords. I love this group and I agree with what Nick said.
You know, I think that I have my failures. I have, you know, to get to $87,000 a month was a bumpy
road. I screwed up so many things, made so many mistakes, got told no so many times, lost Bo's.
This is part of what we do, right? Like you're going to have success look like this, you know,
and it's fun to watch people getting closes and wins and things like that. But behind every one
of those, there's no's and there's, you know, people that are, you know, laser focused and
don't give up and then they post their wins. So it's fun to be on this journey with you guys. And
I'm glad to be on the call today. Well, Ryan, appreciate you, bro. And guys, again, for those
of you that did not get the beta discount, if you guys want to give RankinRant Engine a try with,
again, just for, just so everybody knows, you do not have to use this tool. It is just the tool
that I'm going to be using exclusively. You're going to see it at the training. You're going to
see me referencing it in every single aspect of this because we actually have Ryan who can control
this tool. But you don't have to use it. If you guys want to, you know, throw some stuff together,
use the sheets and the whole deal, I did that. But what I'm telling you is from experience,
it's better to just start and build a proper foundation and scale it up than throw together
a duct tape business and try to retroactively fix it. That is very, very difficult. It's so
much easier if you build it from the ground up, you have your projects lined out, you have your
tasks lined out, you have your freaking due diligence. It's all in one place. You log in,
boom, boom, boom. You have one tool you need, done. But again, I don't want anyone to feel like they
have to. But if you guys are interested, message me. I have a coupon code for you guys. Those of
you that didn't get the beta discount, we have something for you. And with that said, we'll see
you on the next call, Ryan. Cool. Thanks for having me on. Go close and flash. Go get some deals. It's
only freaking Tuesday. We got time, man. It's Tuesday morning for you guys. We got time to go
sling some freaking deals this week, man. By the way, let me mention one more thing.
Today's Election Day, everyone's kind of been weird because it's like, I don't know what's going
to happen. Well, hopefully after today, maybe by Saturday. I know I was reading earlier, like
the George Bush Al Gore one took a couple weeks. But it seems like after this, whatever happens,
people at least have some clarity. And I feel like that things start to become a little bit normal,
at least until the holidays. And then it gets a little weird. But I know that the economy's weird,
people are uncertain. So I'm super optimistic because no matter what, people are always anxious.
After today, tomorrow, this week, we should start seeing things normalize a little bit. So
I'm kind of looking forward to that. A hundred percent. A hundred percent.
Okay guys, talk soon. Appreciate it, Ryan. Thanks for having me on, man. See you.